fin a la armonía en el salvador en el
día del bicentenario de centroamérica
miles de salvadoreños salieron a
protestar en contra del presidente en
allí bukele sus políticas y su deriva
autoritaria un descontento social que
viene de largo y que la instauración del
bitcoin como moneda nacional ha sacado a
relucir como una más de su larga lista
de polémicas reformas
rechazamos contundentemente
la ley impuesta del bitcoin como también
estamos en contra del desmantelamiento
de las instituciones democráticas que
fueron creadas por los acuerdos de paz
las marchas transcurrieron
mayoritariamente sin incidentes salvo
algún hecho aislado como la quema de un
cajero de bitcoins y de varias
motocicletas algo que el dirigente
recriminó
dicen que el vandalismo fue hecho por
infiltrados pero han hecho vandalismo en
todas sus manifestaciones además porque
no se escuchan gritos de deténgase o no
hagan eso lo que se escucha son aplausos
y vítores y ahí está la prensa
esta es la primera manifestación masiva
contra el presidente en allí bukele
desde que asumió la presidencia hace dos
años de hecho bukele goza de índices de
popularidad récord como mandatario
latinoamericano con cerca de un 80 por
ciento de respaldo del pueblo no
obstante políticas como el impulso de
una reforma constitucional para poder
ser reelegido la decisión de duplicar
los efectivos militares o su pacto con
las pandillas empiezan a manchar su
imagen